we had our bachelor alumni it was hot it
was sexy
we had musical meltdowns and we had a
secret villain striking again she's fake
as hell this is your The Bachelor
presents listen to your heart episode
three recap grab your glasses it's time
for roses and Rose day everyone it's me
Lauren Zima and the red of this blanket
represents the blood spilled by Julia hi
everybody how are you are you doing all
right are you doing acceptable are you
even Pleasant well these are all
wonderful adjectives that could be used
for how everyone is if Julia didn't
bring her words into this song oh I am
drinking a red red wine today for all of
the song for all the things Julia did
for all the blood that she spilled kids
she's not fine jewelry has a villain you
guys it's nauseating why aren't we
talking about this maybe you are talking
about this did you think Julia was a
villain let me know in the comments
below and I'm gonna go mm-hmm well
that's good that's good red wine in the
spring I don't know but the quarantine
is turning things upside down isn't it
so on this episode we had performances
we had alumni we had an upping the ante
on glitz and glam didn't we so I've gone
very glam today I am shiny head to toe
you know normally in the real world I
would say that this outfits a little too
much but here on this show in these
times I don't think it is no no no
certainly not so keep shining keep
shining no wear whatever you want to
make yourself feel good in the cool run
teen and make sure your cup doesn't
spill the blood looked really didn't
stop okay
[Music]
let's get to it we start off with the
mansion with a couple of people doing
yoga I think or headstands I don't know
I couldn't see who it was but all I
wrote down was mood mood mood they said
what a time to be alive and what are we
doing today what are we doing today you
know what cheers to whoever you guys
were do you feel like you know everyone
on the show at this point I still don't
and we lost some unknowns in this
episode who are you liking the most who
are you connecting with the most oh God
you guys if I started choking you
couldn't help me through the screen that
would be so hard like dark you just be
recording me dying and you couldn't help
me I'm talking to Chris Anna and JC
they're on a zoom behind mr. cameras say
you guys now this is dark okay waking up
Dan for the rose ceremony I'm feeling
good so it's the morning after the rose
ceremony and this guy Gabe is talking
and we hadn't seen much of Gabe but he
is a secret hottie so cheers to that
how are you good hi dad um Brandon and
Julia are quite literally having a
water-cooler conversation about their
relationship like leaning on a water
cooler as much as times have changed
we're all still talking to the water
cooler I don't know do we have an
espresso machine are you that Keurig
what's happening okay what about one of
those wine machines Oh
he's telling Julia oh I meant to
Savannah and then at the water cooler
he's being very unclear he's been like
oh no no no no Julia I'm into you
I go to Savannah my rose because then
you shared him give you his rose and so
I knew that you would still be here that
we could figure things out it's still
something I long person drink every time
somebody used share it in this episode
trying to collaborate with Sheridan
while living with Brandon is so freakin
annoying poor Sheridan Sharon none all
he's doing a share ring and none too
good for him hmm
and Julie was saying her heart was torn
but then she's saying she's crazy about
Brandon I am crazy about him
hey everybody come here to join me in
the living room please Prince Harrison
is here to up the ante everybody this
morning everything is about to change
he says they all have to figure out
where they're at in their relationships
at work now this morning you didn't have
time to put on makeup you don't have
time to put your contacts in figured
they'd say a shout okay okay and
Brandon's face it's like his whole world
of dating two women at once just
exploded in his face so I'm really glad
that we're gonna be able to do this
together so these couples are all
conversing and Bree and Chris are having
a conversation I literally can't imagine
this without you and you know Chris
tells her in the most monotone way but
he is so sure about her agrees 100 he's
like 100 percent 100 a bazillion hundred
thousand billion zillion percent maybe
they should stick to singing their
feelings I think
every part of screaming yeah yeah oh I
think that was working better for them I
was not expecting that and then the
women are all talking about where
they're at with the men and Julia
strikes again
the initial off the bat like spark for
me was with Brandon this is why Julia is
a secret villain you guys because she's
beautiful and she seems kind and she's
talented she is messy okay she is as
down and dirty as my hair is right now
and that's an something so she tells
Savannah that she and Brandon had this
talk last night we got to have a really
significant Savannah is shocked because
she thought Brandon was only into her
but of course Julia acts like the hero
that did not feel good because I was
like how fair is that to Savannah and
Sheridan
I'm now thinking that Brandon and Julia
deserve each other what do you guys
think let me know in the comments below
so Savannah's just trying to like chill
she's trying to reflect she's trying to
figure things out and gold comes in okay
Gabe this timing couldn't have been
worse all right you're good looking but
you don't have good timing okay
so what do you want to happen she's all
upset about Brandon and he comes in to
talk about his feelings for her I know
confidently that there's no way in which
I could honestly continue on the show if
I wasn't coupled with you just felt that
it was so so clear that Savannah was not
interested at all
oh poor savannah she is crying she is
feeling bad about things with Gabe
because she doesn't have feelings for
him I don't know if there was like that
romantic spark and her jacket is as
shiny as her tears shiny I'm shiny for
Savannah I stand with Savannah who do
you guys stand with Savannah or Julia
let me know in the comments below okay
Oh God and then she really is sobbing
she is freaking out at production like
two seconds could I have two seconds she
is crashing to the floor
don't drink for every time Savannah the
musician out of meltdown a musical
meltdown I need to go home like two
seconds seconds softer Gabe because what
an exit I think perhaps the most
peaceful exit in the history of the show
I mean he actually said that laying out
his heart to Savannah was quote
comforting just completely laying my
heart out there for Savannah was was
comforting I really hope and pray for
nothing about the best first here's to
gave I think the women missed out on
Gabe I think that's a good guy I think
if we can get him to paradise Gabe's a
hot come out of it okay yeah hey you
know I'm saying okay
but Oh don't settle in too quickly
because Savannah is still crying and
Brandon he's like Savannah
and what's wrong what's going on you you
are Brandon you are what's wrong you are
the problem here there can water cooler
conversations yeah and this this this is
the shiny materials don't breathe they'd
help for you tonight I have chosen to
sit in front of a fire on a 90 degree
day so own your choices Julia and also
myself I'm plenty of myself saying that
mm-hmm and drinking a red that's us warm
okay and keep it away from the fire
wonder if the ghost girls here you here
girl you part of the heat okay love and
light
I wonder if she's old enough to drink
okay
Brandon is now back to Savannah I'd like
to move forward with you he is totally
into her and he said something to her
that I thought was so arrogant do you
want to continue with me or do you want
to go home and cry you want to do this
you want to go home okay all right those
my options Brandon what about the option
to go home and say buying a to you all
right
at least give it a shot don't drink
every time Brandon says want to do this
you wanna do this do this do something
what an invite if want to do this do you
want to do this look like let's Jude
should do this I mean Brandon's moods
are changing with each meal you know
we're having coffee we're on Julia we're
at brunch it's on Savannah what's gonna
happen by the time cocktail hour rolls
around Brandon full steam ahead captain
I know what's gonna happen I'm gonna be
hanging out with all my friends okay
this is Grenache nice to meet you how
are you okay
[Music]
drink every time Sheridan is too nice of
a guy Julia sobbing over Brandon because
he's decided to go to Savannah instead
of her so I definitely want to see where
Julia's head's at at this point and kind
of what she's thinking
Sika moments an hour a day because we
have the time to talk about this comment
Julia says she has to forgive herself
the process of what for what
what are you forgiving yourself for
Julia I feel better about it now drink
every time Sheridan says something naive
I know this has nothing to do with us
feel better about it now she feels
confident before the mean and I've like
made peace with it Chris Harrison is
back drink every time he yells on this
show hey everybody come in and join me
in the living room please don't drink
for every time Chris Harrison drops a
piece of information on everybody each
of you as couples are about to have an
amazing opportunity we find out that
they're going to perform as couples each
couple are gonna be given a song you're
gonna be well-known and that the judges
are musicians and bachelor couples okay
boo better to judge what you're going
through and understand what you're going
through
than these guys and this probably is
interesting to me because the couples do
seem to be quite strong together right
I'm not sure about the talent of some of
these voices but when they're with
another person you know we're stronger
together and that's also a message of
all this the quarantine I know that last
week I said I wasn't gonna mention it
but I do think that sometimes we have to
allude to it because it is the reality
in which we are all living and you know
what at the end of the day we can still
keep it shake everybody I mean look at
me I'm shiny head to toe including my
sweat I'm
usually a drink will do the trick take
the edge off cliffs in in so they're all
practicing and this is interesting right
because you guys it's not easy to work
with someone you're in - am i right I
know from personal experience though I
will also say great to work with someone
you're into you got stuff in common I
don't hang it on it that whole phrase
about not you know wedding where you eat
I say you know what you know what were
you drink okay that's gonna get you
through all right so they're practicing
and Julia's making things all about her
drink every time it she does something
mean to share it in feels icky doesn't
feel right and I want to point out she's
using some choice words confused some
select adjectives and frustrated some
specific vocabulary indecisive she says
trying to collaborate with Sheridan is
annoying trying to collaborate with
Sheridan while living with Brandon is so
freaking annoying what I had with
Brandon is what I'm missing with
Sheridan it's kind of hard to pour
myself fully into what I have was shared
that guy
oh you know then we're gonna blow
through the next moment that we have
because we get a date card Rebecca and
Danny the theater kids see we haven't
seen much of you know what they did get
a higher budget date though they go to a
house we not be in a house but it is in
the Hollywood Hills and there are some
beautiful pieces of clothing glam glam
glam I really support you guys still
dressing up during these times I truly
believe that still getting yourself
together can help you keep it together
Julie is that the water cooler again
drink her every time she has a water
cooler conversation I have very little
respect for Brandon and Savannah at this
moment in time Julia try the bar go to
the bar she calls Brandon and Savannah
bizarre for people who just weren't
doing this 12 hours ago it's our game
Julia mmm-hmm
honestly at this point I feel like she's
doing bad to the Julian name because
there are a lot of Julia's we left Julia
Roberts as I said last week Julia Child
Julia Louie Dreyfus Wow my [ __ ] queen
do you guys watch beep got it blew
through that show I love it so much made
me want to live in DC for a while I
fantasized about it anyway Oh Jesse and
Christy are like Gary and Amy but I
think I'm nicer you have set fire to the
drunk
and you know it was wild Becca and Danny
bless them had the best date so far on
this show it almost felt like just a
goodbye like a thank you for being here
a thank you for being here today thank
you for being here today and also a mime
they had a beautiful house glamorous
clothes a hot tub champagne and after
all that you know what Becca did not
have for Danny even just a peck on the
lips
she wouldn't even give Danny uh uh okay
it's so awkward right first of all he
was wanting to figure things out with me
24 hours ago and now we are back to
Julia and she is saying Savannah is and
I quote fake as hell she's fake as hell
I'm not willing to be fake
do close to the flames Julia I just
don't know how I process people being so
outrageously dishonest to get ahead oh
she says she doesn't know how to process
people who are being outrageously
dishonest
you took Sheridan's rose and said you
were crazy about Brandon I am crazy
about him
you told Savannah you wanted to treat
her and Sheridan fairly how fair is that
to Savannah and Sheridan but you told
Brandon behind her back that she was odd
and not getting along with other women
and of all the girls she's kind of plays
it close to the vest which feels like a
little odd documents thoughts of these
are documents okay and now she wants to
leave because of Savannah I will to
leave because you know what Julia I was
a magazine journalism major in college I
did a lot of writing I did a lot of
editing so let me give you a few choice
adjectives for how I'm feeling incensed
indignant I rates
okay but so hot um I think we need a
one-on-one conversation with you so
Julia confronts Savannah I don't really
know about what what did you think of
this moment I found it to be as Julia
would say bizarre for her to be coming
at Savannah what is Savannah down here
she calls her disingenuous
it feels disingenuous hey son what
Savannah as far as I can see has been
honest with everyone and I found
Savannah's explanation of her actions
with Brandon and her PDA to be 100%
sensical you got to start doing music
and now I feel so comfortable I'm so
safe and I've seen his personality come
out and I felt the permission to be me
let me know in the comments below
use your words use some adjectives throw
in some nouns I mean with certain mounds
people places luckily we still have
things you know at the end of the day I
think Julia's just mad because Brandon
picked Savannah not her that's not very
chic no it's not so she says she's not
in Savannah's business I'm not in your
business she is and then she says she
doesn't have feelings for Brandon I
don't have any feelings for pretendin so
she does and then Julia says she isn't
coming from a place of wishing she was
with Brandon but she just said that this
is not coming from a place where I'm
like oh I wish I was with Brandon I am
crazy about him but let's do a change
your face now we're on a date with
Natasha and Ryan
I guess when did they get a date card
did I miss that last night Natasha and I
got a date card what's happening you
know whatever because the cruise Lane
and Lauren Bushnell are here and that's
amazing happily married adore them both
great
cheers to Chris Lane for saying what
we've all been thinking that Ryan looks
like Shawn Mendes I thought you're Shawn
Mendes standing out here Natasha and
Ryan of a date it's great I guess they
kiss against a wall they're like this
because I I felt a little more at ease
watching Ryan kiss from a distance you
know from far away that was easier
or two summers you imagine so everyone's
practicing for their big performances
and Jamie is running away she's so
nervous for pressure I just wish I
didn't get so nervous I don't want to
ruin it for him and I just got so
worried for her running on that tile be
careful on that tile Jamie what Bri
that's Santa Barbara tile oh oh and it's
the performances and Chris Harrison is
in a light gray suit what's the best
suit color for guys to wear let me know
in the comments below
for me it's light gray okay give a warm
welcome to Jojo oh the judges are Jojo
and Jordan and I love them both so much
and Kesha and jason mraz wonderful
beautiful what a combination of Bachelor
royalty and musical pedigree so you know
don't drink for every performance
[Music]
vn Jamie is freaking out again
she says her fear is to be judged and I
wrote down my babe I don't know if this
business is for you yes and then and
then we get some more word Becca and
Danny moments she literally moves her
lips to not kiss him I mean anything
like that you guys he went in for a kiss
and she went he went in for a kiss and
she went well let me do that a little
closer I can't even I can't even really
move my face in the way that she was
moving it like that and I thought that
it would be over there it wasn't it's
gonna get worse
gonna get worse because then he tries to
get her on stage and oh it was still so
awkward and then they sing and then he
went for it again and I suddenly cannot
I cannot I cannot I did not think I
could be made to feel so awkward in the
quarantine when I'm not even around
other people did feel uncomfortable but
it came through the screen so then
Brandon and Savannah are performing and
this was intriguing the judges did not
feel the vibes from Brandon and Savannah
in terms of their interest to me and I
felt like you kept pulling away a little
bit and I feel like Brandon was really
trying to lock the eyes I thought
Savannah was maybe just nervous what did
you think let me know in the comments
below we could have done with a better
explanation but Julia no she's not
worried about an explanation she's
making faces she's like ding ding ding
ding ding ding Oh Julia put the bow down
[Music]
always been a friend and then Julia in
the man she is using are singing and I
want to point out that Savannah did not
make any mean faces during their
performance and you know what just
cheers to Jo Jo and Jordan a nice couple
and I like them mm-hmm commands oh yes
at the end here Julia is literally
laughing at Savannah's pain so I imagine
this super painful for Savannah right
now
[Music]
okay the performances are continuing and
I kind of forgotten about Natasha this
episode but oh then she is singing and I
remembered
Natasha with the vocal stylings booboo
can bail
[Music]
why just singers do this I don't know
what the I don't know why you plugged
the one year but I like it odds don't
drink for every strange air nozzle Ryan
gives her during their performance I
mean I don't know what that was about
their performance was wonderful I think
they're both talented I don't know how
to touch this hair color changed how'd
she get her hair done in The Bachelor
quarantine went from blonde to brunette
Ben's gonna be Jaime and Trevor and
she's so hard on herself it's just crazy
to think of how much I get in my own
head
she's always talking about her whole
life like my whole freakin life mm ah
I don't know why but she's even doing
squats backstage to calm down why what's
this doing Jaime all it's doing is
getting my heart rate up oh that's the
most cardio I've done in weeks and in a
pleather pants that was a choice
[Music]
but Jamie and Trevor get through it and
don't drink every time she
hyperventilates post-performance and now
we have a rose ceremony and Becca and
Danny are going home right I don't want
to cancel the theater kids but they are
but before that we need Julia to make
one more comment
she says it's ironic that the judges
called her and Sheridan genuine
ironically they used the word genuine
for me and shared which felt really good
because that's kind of what I've been
saying that I just wish everyone would
be Jamie Trevor and Chris Harrison is
calling out who gets the Rose okay okay
okay
more where that came from in this house
honestly Julia Sheridan Julia and
Sheridan are staying and she punches the
air
Danny and Becca go home and we are not
surprised and Julia even though she has
said that she no longer had feelings for
Brandon I don't have any feelings for
pretendin she is now expressing that she
can't help but wonder if he's still
thinking about her I'm just wondering if
Brandon still thinking about me all
right everyone that's a wrap on roses
and Rose a listen to your heart episode
3 and of course I'm keepin it chic
keepin it elegant what can we do in the
quarantine other than elevate ourselves
keep it stylish keep it classic I love
you guys so much thank you for watching
we will be here for you every week all
my love bye I just don't want to get too
close to the fire okay
[Music]